pendant commencer par cette violence qui
s'exprime dans les rues presque
quotidiennement
vous avez sans doute vu hier ces
policiers qui s'en prenaient très
durement aux pompiers
regardez
[Musique]
ma
voilà donc on se perçoit que les black
block ou les gilet jaune n'ont pas le
monopole des affrontements très dur avec
la police il ya eu aussi eu ses autres
images de violence plus symbolique
c'était lors d'une manifestation aux
flambeaux le 24 janvier dernier
on voyait la tête du président de la
république en tout cas sa représentation
au bout d'une pique
alors est ce que c'est une image faite
pour frapper les médias ou est ce que
c'est quelque chose de plus grave
écoutez le point de vue très très fort
de l'ancien garde des sceaux robert
badinter pour lui c'est grave ce degré
de violence non pas physique en cours
mais verbal rien la démonstration la
représentation d'une tête au bout d'une
pique nuitées et pour moi à mes yeux
absolument totalement condamnable voilà
avant d'ouvrir le débat je vous propose
d'écouter un autre point de vue assez
différent c'est celui d'un autre ancien
ministre luc ferry le philosophe qui a
aussi était un ministre de l'éducation
nationale et qui s'exprimait il ya une
dizaine de jours sur lci pour dire que
tout ça n'avait rien de nouveau et
emmanuel macron n'était pas le premier à
avoir affaire à ce genre de deux prises
à partie un peu vive
c'est arrivé à tous les présidents de la
république au l'on ne pouvait plus
bouger à la fin de son quinquennat
giscard sous les phares dont de gaulle
de gaulle non plus n 7 après files
d'attentes à 27 tentatives d'attentats
contre de gaulle bonbons à l'activé la
mare soit un niveau
giscard sort sous les quolibets les
insultes abominable sort de l'elysée bon
voila si on revenait 30 ans en arrière
ces choses-là n'existerait pas parce
qu'elle serait pas médiatiser tout
simplement car ce parti est ce que est
ce que cette violence est inédite
alors je pense qu'on peut pas nier le
climat actuel qui est une sorte de
prurit près insurrectionnelle qui
effectivement c'est vraiment enkystée
depuis
dernière avec gilet jaune d'ailleurs si
vous aimez âgées insurrectionnel c'est
dans certains hao certains certains je
pense à certains moments où on n'en est
pas loin de cette image de macron la
tête de maquereaux au bout d'une pique
on l'a déjà vu en tout cas elle a été
évoqué même dans les slogans l'année
dernière par les jets les jaunes donc
s'il ya une forme de continuité
je pense qu'il faut distinguer en fait
ce qui est une violence d'une france du
service public au sens large qui à bout
parce que ils n'ont plus les moyens
d'exercer leur profession et de remplir
leur office dans de bonnes conditions
d'un autre d'une autre france plus
marginale plus plus resserrée qui veut
elle rejouer la lutte des classes
finalement avec ce slogan bas quand on
est dans les clous on ne nous entend pas
donc c'est la faute des dirigeants si
finalement on passe au coup de force
alors en fait on sait bien qu'en théorie
politique à deux façons de voir la
violence la première c'est procédér et
que la violence c'est un moyen regretta
regrettables mais nécessaires pour
assurer la cohésion d'une société et
dans ces cas-là l'état a le monopole
légitime de la violence et selon la
fameuse formule de max weber et avec
l'aval des citoyens et puis il ya une
deuxième lecture qui tout à fait
différente qui considère que la violence
c'est le moteur de l'histoire
ça c'est une lecture qui nous vient des
gueules de marque c'est pour ça que je
parlais de lutte des classes tout à
l'heure et que donc dans ce cas là la
violence de l'êta n'est pas plus
légitime que celle de ses opposants et
que donc si l'état utilise des moyens
violents et ben pourquoi pas en face
utiliser des moyens violents
tout ça est parfaitement justifiée alors
je pense je rappelle ça parce que je
pense qu'on est on est un peu dans ce
dans cette disjonction là aujourd'hui et
alors on voit bien la logique parce que
dire que l'état donc ils censés être
détenteur légitime de la violence est
finalement une espèce de syndicats de
technocrates élitiste qui ne s'occupe
que de leurs intérêts ils ne considèrent
pas là le peuple dans tout son et ne le
représente pas eh ben on justifie en
quelque sorte cette forme de violence
sociale et c'est évidemment donner un
petit peu laval à ce type de violence
qu'on voit chez les
c'est ce temps ou chez des militants de
groupes plus limité et à mon sens c'est
vraiment vraiment contraire à l'esprit
c'est pour ça que je rejoins badinter
je boucle là dessus je pense que c'est
totalement contraire à l'esprit de la
démocratie qui en fait consiste telle
que je la comprends moi je ne suis pas
la seule à essayer de dépasser le
conflit le surmonter par la négociation
la recherche du consensus
c'est le consensus conflictuelle non par
les rigueurs donc je pense qu'il a tout
à fait raison c'est partager ce point de
vue c'est que cette violence elle est à
la fois revendicatrice d'ailleurs ça
peut marcher puisque les les pompiers
ont obtenu gain de cause le ministre de
l'intérieur leur a dit qu il allait
préserver leur régime spécial
elle est à la fois revendicatrice et
révolutionnaire ce qui est paradoxal
c'est que hier en même temps qu on avait
ces violences cours de vincennes
on avait la discussion avec les
organisations représentatives des
pompiers au ministère de l'intérieur qui
ont en effet obtenu gain de cause
notamment sur ce qu'on appelle la prime
de feu les pompiers comme d'autres
personnels de la fonction publique vous
avez raison expriment des revendications
liées à la pénibilité à la dangerosité
de leur métier lié aussi à la prise en
compte de leurs spécificités dans le
cadre de la réforme des retraites
notamment
vous avez aussi des professions du
secteur public comme les enseignants qui
pour certains ont fait la grève des
copies c'était lié à la mise en oeuvre
qui s'estiment et mauvaises de la
réforme du baccalauréat alors on peut
discuter sur chacun de ces points mais
ce qu'on constate c'est que ce sont des
revendications sectorielles
essentiellement dans le secteur public
même s'il est vrai que notamment chez
les avocats il ya aussi des
revendications dans le secteur privé non
pensée qui me semble qu'il faut
distinguer ses revendications qui sont
en effet légitime dans une démocratie
qui doivent appeler le pouvoir politique
à rentrer dans une discussion une
négociation même faut les distinguer ça
vous dit justement non mais justement il
faut les distinguer de ses violences
parce que là la manifestation d'hier il
n'y a pas eu que des violences
il ya eu ces scènes extrêmement choquant
et qui sont une certaine manière
une défaite de la république quand on
voit des policiers et des pompiers qui
se tapent dessus c'est une défaite
collective
il n'y a pas que ça aujourd'hui dans
leurs revendications et je termine
simplement en disant une chose c'est que
le rôle du politique dans une période
comme celle ci me semble-t-il c'est d'en
appeler à la responsabilité de chacun on
sort quand même d'une période où vous
avait un élu du front national qui a
exprimé son opinion que le président de
la république ne serait pas de france
vous avez une ancienne candidate à la
présidentielle socialiste qui explique
que le pays est quasiment une dictature
j'aime autorités un autre régime
autoritaire ne pas la nommer il faut
vraiment que chacun revienne à la raison
et les paroles en l'espèce d'un ancien
ministre socialiste version avec
mélenchon qui dit aussi que dans un
régime autorise la haine des médias chez
jean luc mélenchon frontenaud vaincu
mais en l'occurrence on attend des voix
et des consciences comme celle de robert
badinter simplement pour ramener à la
raison
il ya des revendications qui peuvent
être légitimes mais pas cette violence
là et pas sous ses formes en tout cas
pas dans une démocratie alors le sujet
vous passionne de toute évidence parce
que nous avons beaucoup de réactions je
vous les livre en vrac puis après ça on
demandera alexandre ii vecchio son point
de vue citoyen paye on nous dit pour
obtenir un droit d'écouter sommet les
pompiers font comme les autres ils
manifestent et sa marche apparemment
effectivement on peut dire aussi que les
gilets jaunes ont obtenu beaucoup en
tout cas 17 milliards d'êtres diverses
parce qu'il manifestait parfois avec
violence chardons bleus pensent de la
même façon qu'on ne peut que constater
qu'il ne se passe rien dans ce pays tant
qu'il n'y a pas de violence ou de grève
et puis là qui relativise r34 qui disait
les tentatives d'attentats contre de
gaulle
ah oui ne sont comparables à rien une
vraie guerre se déroulait à l'époque
effectivement donc le le c'était les
événements d'algérie et la situation
française était peut-être encore plus
tendue certainement même et babineau
pense aussi que la société a toujours
été violente
c'est la sur médiatisation de cette
violence qui est un nouveau phénomène
alexandre de vécu qu'est ce que vous en
pensez déjà dans les images il faut
distinguer les violences la première
avec la tête au bout d'une pique c'est
une violence purement symbolique plutôt
des codes de la gauche radicale qui sont
pas les miens mais enfin ça existe
depuis la révolution française pour le
coup je suis plutôt d'accord avec avec
luc ferry pour coup pendant la
révolution française ça existait au vrai
mais c'est pas pour ça que quand on
utilise ces images que ça va se traduire
dans la réalité je crois qu'il faut
distinguer justement ce qui relève des
mouvements d'humeur de ce qui relève de
la violence réelle et parfois il ya une
forme de catharsis dans ce genre de
manifestation qui est plutôt bienvenu
qui éveille qui évite justement la
violence real donc moi quand je vois les
propos de robert badinter
s'il voit un peu la grande peur des
biens pour sow ou celle des
centre-villes
d'une certaine manière donc voilà pour
le ces violences symboliques la violence
qui est plus préoccupant c'est quand
même celle des qui est inédite pour le
coup enfin pas inédites parce que ça
existait il ya quelques mois sous macro
mais c'est c'est une grande première
qu'on doit aux gouvernements macro c'est
l'affrontement des forces de l'ordre
entre elles les pompiers comme les
policiers sont censés représenter les
institutions et les voir se taper dessus
et quand même très spectaculaire et très
étonnant et détonnant et je crois que
c'est le symptôme d'un délitement
absolue de l'état et de de l'autorité de
l'état c'est d'autant plus dommage que
ces forces de l'ordre se font taper
dessus
dans certains territoires on sait que
les pompiers se font caillasser les
policiers aussi donc les voit
aujourd'hui se taper dessus ou se dit
que l'état et qui est quand même
extrêmement paupérisée je crois que
c'est un signal à signal d' alerte très
important si j'avais un conseil à leur
donner ce serait peut-être de manifester
bras dessus bras dessous contre contre
emmanuel macron plutôt que de
s'affronter je pense que ce sera plus
efficace
pascal perrin ne nous a rejoint bonsoir
de nous posions cette question savoir si
ces violences qui se manifestent chaque
jour était sporadique ou si elles
étaient le reflet de de l'état profond
de la société alors vous qui sont des la
france réclamant vous qui avez été je le
rappelle l'un des cinq gars en c'est à
dire une sorte de caution du grand débat
national est ce que vous êtes surpris
par cette violence ou est-ce qu'elles
reflètent ce que vous vous avez pu
ressentir dans ce dans ce tour de france
du grand débat non là où ça ne surprend
personne
ça ne surprend personne pourquoi parce
que la colère la violence verbale elle a
toujours existé et vous aviez raison de
rappeler souvenons nous par exemple de
l'entre-deux-guerres par exemple la lavi
race verbal la violence dans les
manifestations étaient au premier plan
et nous avons déjà connu même après
cette période des périodes
d'affrontements mai 68 enfants pourrait
citer de multiples exemples cependant il
y a eu pendant longtemps des moyens de
refroidir la colère s'étaient tous les
corps intermédiaires les grands partis
les grands syndicats les grandes
institutions qui refroidit zay et donner
du sens à la colère maintenant comme le
dit denis maillard qui a beaucoup lu et
étudié le mouvement des gilet jaune
les colères reste chaude il n'y a plus
de refroidissement de la colère la
colère devient presque un projet de vie
un projet de mobilisation se mobilisent
parce qu'on est en colère
ça avait commencé avec le libelle que
beaucoup de gens avaient trouvé
formidable qui était de stéphane hessel
vous savez le fameux indignés 20
techniques et un dîner vous mais
pourquoi comment il faut bien un jour
sortir de l'indignation sortir de la
colère et là on voit bien qu'il y à une
violence dans la société française qui
est une violence verbale mais attention
la violence verbale et symbolique elle
annonce souvent des violences d'une
autre nature
et on voit bien que dans toutes les
enquêtes a lancé très difficile
d'interroger les français par exemple en
disant est ce que vous allez déposer une
bombe
est ce que vous allez commettre un
attentat ou es ce que vous avez même
envie de de casser la figure aux forces
de l'ordre
mais dans les intentions des dire par
exemple est ce que vous trouvez
justifier le fait qu'on occupe des
bâtiments publics
le fait que l'on brûle tel ou tel
symbole ça ne cesse de monter et vous
avez dans la jeunesse française à
potentiel de radicalité aujourd'hui
alors on a beaucoup parlé de la
radicalité religieuse elle est là mais
il ya un autre type de radicalité qui
est une radicalité qu'on pourrait
appeler politique ou infra politique et
qui se traduit maintenant dans tous les
corps même les corps et vous aviez
raison de le rappeler
deux sapeurs pompiers professionnels
dont certains sont militaires vous savez
que sur les quarante mille je crois
sapeurs pompiers professionnels
il y en a tout même 8000 qui sont des
militaires n'ont pas droit à manifester
ils n'ont pas vraiment fait de marseille
sa peur pompiers de touques a fait ils
n'ont pas le droit de manifester mais
hier vous aviez tout de même des sapeurs
pompiers qui manifestait avec leur
casque qui n'ont pas respecté
l'itinéraire prévu qu'ils voulaient se
rendre vers le périphérique pour le
bloquer donc il ya là tout de même
quelque chose qui a changé quelque chose
qui a changé
quel est le signe certainement d'un
délitement de l'état mais bien au delà
je crois d'un changement de comportement
et d'attitude les colères sociales
aujourd'hui ne trouve plus aucune
canalisations donc elles deviennent en
effet extrêmement disruptive aidé le
mouvement social est aussi 10 trucs tiff
qui emmanuel macron avait pu l'être en
2010 est dans le champ politique avec
thank you pascal perrineau parler de
l'aspect générationnel de cette colère
voulu vous avez consacré 1
un livre se paie les enfants du siècle
c'est ça aa77 génération peut-être plus
politisé et plus radicalisés que les
précédentes voulez vous les voyez là
alors on voit que l'orage moi c'était
des jeunes la vingtaine là je pense
qu'il ya des gens de toutes les
tous les âges mais effectivement ça
c'était j'avais le pressentiment qu'on
allait vers une certaine radicalisation
même si j'aime pas ce mot parce qu'il
renvoie à l'islam radical je crois que
c'est papa la même chose mais
effectivement pour sortait du cadre des
affrontements traditionnel droite gauche
qui avait nord une quête d'identité
d'appartenance dans la jeunesse face à à
un modèle qui n'avait plus tellement de
sens et qu'on allait vers de nouvelles
formes politiques je crois qu'on est
dedans tout à l'heure on parle on disait
la démocratie c'est la recherche du
consensus certes mais c'est la recherche
de construction du conflit surmonter
mais juste bon je crois je crois qu'à
des problèmes démocratiques aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il ya plus tellement de conflit
entre les représentants et du coup il ya
un conflit entre les représentants elle
est représentée dans une démocratie
saine il faut qu'il ya un réel
antagonismes or aujourd'hui
on a la victoire est d'ailleurs
maquereau en est le symbole finalement
du cercle de la raison qui est au
pouvoir une espèce de croissance mène
mélenchon cours à la hausse - ça oui
mais sont encore ils sont d'abord
présentés à l'assemblée nationale où
très peu pour le coup marine le pen est
arrivée mais quoi qu'on pense d'elle au
second tour a fait quand même des
milieux 1 voix sur son nom être là n'a
pas de groupe à l'assemblée nationale et
donc je crois que c'est un réel problème
et ça ça fait qu'on a et l epa cash flow
plus comme un espoir réel d'alternative
politique ce qui fait qu on est
effectivement dans quelque chose de
l'itil où il ya plus de corps
intermédiaires et où on à la base le
peuple ou du moins une partie du peuple
qui se retrouve directement face à face
à avai que ses représentants et je crois
que c'est la situation effectivement
politique inédite d'aujourd'hui et que
c'est pas propre au cas français pascal
perrineau pernaut je sens aussi chez les
jeunes une vraie dimension anarchisante
au delà même de la contestation il ya
quelque chose de cet ordre là qui est
qui me semble assez récent et qui s'est
beaucoup passionné c'est toutes
dernières années oui et ça s'est nourrie
en effet de ce cimetière des idéologies
qui est devenu le champ politique
français et on en revient à des formes
de mobilisation qu'on avait pu connaître
au moment où les grandes idéologies
était en train de se cristalliser qu'il
y avait en france en effet par exemple
une violence anarchiste
donc vous avez wind et puis vous avez
des types de mobilisation d'un qu'on
appelle souvent des mobilisations d'un
nouveau type comme par exemple la
mobilisation offerte
alors il ya une mobilisation verte
extrêmement pacifique mais regardez
comment vous voyez apparaître au sein
même de la mobilisation écologique
aujourd'hui des comportements de plus en
plus radicaux c'est à dire on va aller
s'attaquer par exemple aux boucheries
on va intervenir par la violence c'est à
dire que vous avez même ce militantisme
qui jusqu'àlors était parée de toutes
les vertus de paix et de sérénité qui
commence à se durcir et qui est
révélateur en effet quand on a plus d'
instrument de projection idéologique
on va avoir une certaine forme de ce que
les anarchistes appelait jadis la
propagande par le fait la propagande par
le comportement
la propagande par l'attitude la
propagande par la violence je corrige le
titre erroné que j'aidais de votre livre
chère à l'exemple de vécurent parce que
y'a des gens qui travaillent en régie et
qui me souffle que il s'agit des
nouveaux enfants du siècle
enquête sur une génération fracturé aux
éditions du cerf et puis on laisse le
dernier mot à élan qui est sans doute
d'accord avec vous quand il explique que
les politiques ne changent pas quel que
soit notre vote et ceci depuis
maastricht pas étonnant après que les
esprits s'échauffent